dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr. Khurana if a head if you
have been watching this series for a
while you know very well that I love
learning algorithms and fluid
simulations but do you know what I like
even better learning algorithms applied
to fluid simulations so I couldn't be
happier with today's paper we can create
wondrous fluid simulations like the ones
you see here
by studying the laws of fluid motion
from physics and write a computer
program that contains these laws as you
see the amount of detail we can simulate
with these programs is nothing short of
amazing however I just mentioned neural
networks if we can write a simulator
that runs the laws of physics to create
these programs why would we need
learning based algorithms the answer is
in this paper that we have discussed
about 300 episodes ago the goal was to
show a neural network video footage of
lots and lots of fluid and smoke
simulations and have it learn how the
dynamics work to the point that it can
continue and guess how the behavior of a
smoke puff would change over time we
stop the video and it would learn how to
continue it if you will this definitely
is an interesting take as normally we
use neural networks to solve problems
that are otherwise close to impossible
to tackle for instance it is very hard
if not impossible to create a
handcrafted algorithm that detects cats
reliably because we cannot really write
down the mathematical description of a
cat however these days we can easily
teach a neural network to do that but
this task here is fundamentally
different here the neural networks are
applied to solve something that we
already know how to solve especially
given that if we use a neural network to
perform this task we have to train it
which is a long and arduous process I
hope to have convinced you that this is
a bad bad idea
why would anyone bother to do that does
this make any sense
well it does make a lot of sense and the
reason for that is that this training
step only has to be done once and
afterwards querying the neural network
that is predicting what happens next in
the simulation runs almost immediately
this takes way less time than
calculating all the forces and pressures
in the simulation while retaining
high-quality results so we suddenly went
from thinking that an idea is useless to
being amazing what are the weaknesses of
the approach generalization you see
these techniques including a newer
variant that you see here can give us
detailed simulations in real time or
close to real time but if we present
them with something that is far outside
of the cases that they had seen in the
training domain they will fail this does
not happen with our hand crafted
techniques only to AI based methods so
onwards to this new technique and you
will see in just a moment that a key
differentiator here is that is
generalization capabilities are just
astounding look here the predicted
results match the true simulation quite
well
look at it in slow motion too so we can
evaluate it a little better
Pingree but we have talked about
superior generalization so what about
that well it can also handle sand and
group simulations so that's a great step
beyond just water and smoke
and now have a look at this one this is
a scene with the boxes it has been
trained on
now let's ask it to try to simulate the
evolution of significantly different
shapes
Wow it not only does well with these
previously unseen shapes but it also
handles their interactions really well
but there is more we can also train it
on a tiny domain with only a few
particles and then it is able to learn
general concepts that we can reuse to
simulate a much bigger domain and also
with more particles fantastic
but there is even more we can train it
by showing how water behaves on these
water ramps and then let's remove the
ramps and see if it understands what it
has to do with all these particles yes
it does now let's give it something more
difficult
I want more ramps yes and now even more
ramps
yes I love it let's see if it can do it
with sand - here is the RAM for the
training and let's try an artless now
absolute witchcraft and we are even
being paid to do this I can hardly
believe this the reason why you see so
many particles in many of these views is
because if we look under the hood we see
that the paper proposes a really cool
graph based method that represents the
particles and they can pass messages to
each other over these connections
between them this leads to a simple
general and accurate model that truly is
a force to be reckoned with now this is
a great leap in neural network based
physics simulations but of course not
everything is perfect here is
generalization capabilities have their
limits for instance over longer time
frames solids may get incorrectly
deformed
however I will quietly note that during
my college years I was also studying the
beautiful navier-stokes equations and
even as a highly motivated student it
took several months to understand the
theory and write my first fluid
simulator you can check out the thesis
and the source code in the video
description if you are interested and to
see that these neural networks could
learn something very similar in a matter
of days every time I think about this
shivers run down my spine absolutely
amazing
what a time to be alive this episode has
been supported by lamda if you're a
researcher or a startup looking for
cheap GPU compute to run these
algorithms check out lamda GPU cloud
I've talked about lambdas GPU
workstations in other videos and I'm
happy to tell you that they are offering
GPU cloud services as well the lambda
GPU cloud can train imagenet to 93%
accuracy for less than $19 lambdas web
based IDE lets you easily access your
instance right in your browser and
finally hold onto your papers because
the lambda GPU cloud costs less than
half of AWS and asier make sure to go to
lambda labs comm slash papers and sign
up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time